make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob um i've got stuff that i got to
do today i have an amazing day today
which by the way uh make sure you guys
come over to twitch.tv slash eat codes
tonight myself and mariah are gonna be
playing fall guys
and doing drinking games
[Laughter]
we're literally probably gonna get drunk
on stream but uh it's gonna be amazing
but uh we're picking back up with secret
wars right we're picking back up with
secret wars and we're near the end we
are on issue number eight and there are
nine issues i wish there had been 12
but such as it is we only have nine so
in the last video we talked about how
this massive battle at the at doomstat
at the realm of god king doom was
basically leading to the fall of
everything right the collapse of of
doomguard and the whole point behind
this was or at least one of the major
things that happened here is you had the
arrival of maestro and his world
breakers right which was more than
enough to turn the tide of battle but
the other thing that we had going on
here and i'm not entirely sure that we
covered this
was thanos traveling to the shield now
we did cover this segment where thanos
got to the shield but once he was there
he actually ended up having a
conversation with the face of ben grimm
where we basically learned that the
thing
was the shield that protected battle
world from all the other threats that
were out there right the annihilation
horde marvel zombies all that kind of
stuff and the way this played out was
that thanos had really kind of told ben
grimm like you've been lied to this
whole time that in another universe and
another time and place
long before the creation of battle world
that there was existence there were
things that were there that you were
told this has always been this way by
god king doom and that was a falsehood
more so than that
in the world before this the reality
before all of this you were a hero
like you were a superhero right and so
essentially it's you've been lied to
this whole time
are you gonna take that sitting down or
are you gonna stand up and it was thanos
playing on the nature of ben grimm
ben grimm to a degree is a very prideful
character but more so than that he
believes in doing what's right and if
god king doom is in fact a false king
and he's ruling battle world under false
pretenses
then thing basically believes in
standing up to that like he believes in
confronting god kingdom
and bringing that to an end also because
the god kingdom lied when he said that
his family was dead
in fact they're all alive all that kind
of stuff but the reality of this is that
ben grimm shows up here
and immediately attacks maestro right
immediately starts going to town on
maestro
and in doing so basically crushes the
ship and seems to destroy maestro in the
process now
do i believe that ben grim could kill
the maestro no and just because you're
of a certain size does not mean
that your strength increases
proportionately well i guess we can kind
of assume that it does with ben grim and
keep in mind
this is an alternate version of the
thing right this is not the main marvel
universe version of his character so it
could be that he's stronger than maestro
right again that's what you're dealing
with when it comes to alternate reality
characters whose powers aren't fully
fleshed out
we're kind of left to believe that he's
similar but we can kind of guess and
make our own call but
the other part of that is that there's a
massive explosion that takes place
and initially the response of black swan
is that the rebels have basically
breached the castle but the response of
doom is
no right we would know if the lowest
levels had been breached that must have
been something else and so what you end
up getting
is basically black swan who kind of goes
to investigate and you've got valeria
richards you know who's kind of like
okay you know like there's not a whole
lot we can do here right like basically
the whole realm of battle world is
essentially falling in this massive
conflict but the next thing that happens
is you have terrax the enlightened who
if you guys recall during jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers was
the herald of galactus in an alternate
reality and when he sees this version of
galactus standing here he initially
approaches him and says hey like you
know in an alternate reality i was your
herald i will be your herald again and
then he's killed by galactus and we end
up finding out this
isn't really galactus as we know him
instead it's basically franklin richards
using him as a kind of puppet and we
also sort of always knew that but it is
really the most pure display of the
power of franklin right we saw that
during hickman's fantastic four that
franklin richards as an adult
resurrected galactus from the dead
it only makes sense to kind of continue
the jonathan hickman theme of writing
that franklin richards would basically
take over galactus he would control him
and use him for whatever his own ends
are now the reality of this is it
doesn't really seem to be galactus as we
know him it's really more of him just
kind of
in a in almost kind of like a dead state
so to speak and frankly just using him
in that way
but regardless there's a massive battle
that takes place between franklin
and galactus here or really just
franklin and ben grimm and you kind of
get this this thing where
once franklin basically reveals the fact
that he is in effect the son of god king
doom that's when
you know ben grimm begins to pick up
like okay wait a minute so you're
susie's kid right he's like yeah it's
like so you're telling me
that susan storm married doctor doom and
they had kids together and the response
of franklin is
yeah and the issue is that ben grimm
can't attack franklin right he's his
nephew he's like i'm not gonna kill you
like i'm not gonna kill you here i can't
kill my own family so you do whatever it
is you have to do and franklin richards
does that he literally blows ben grimm
apart right he kills ben grimm on the
spot
which was nuts when it happened it was
like jeez everything is quite literally
collapsing
the other thing that goes on here and
it's kind of a small little moment here
is of course you have the maker and you
have reed richards in the main marvel
universe who basically locate the source
of dr doom's power thanks to the efforts
of
peter parker and miles morales and then
essentially travel to that location
leaving uh peter quill behind in order
to keep an eye on the ship right to
basically make sure that nobody takes
the ship but the other thing that goes
on is there's this massive explosion
right this kind of you know huge
kind of you know huge boom that takes
place and that's when doom realizes here
they come right because
with ben grimm basically abandoning his
role of the shield
it leaves a gaping hole right and doom
knew that from that hole would come like
the annihilation horde or something like
that and that's exactly what happened
the annihilation horde comes pouring in
all of whom are led by thanos and so
with that happening you basically have
valeria who tells her mom
come with me right like it's important
that you understand the bigger picture
here we've been lied to
for a long time you need to really
understand what's going on here with
doctor doom the other part of this this
is probably one of the coolest moments
in the whole story you pick back up with
peter quill right and you have black
swan who shows up here to confront peter
quill
you know where he's kind of looking at
the ship making sure that it's all in
good working order you know she's like
what are you doing here
he spots her and it's like what are you
doing and she's like i'm serving my god
right destroying those who stand against
him and so it becomes
obvious right off the bat the two of
them are gonna fight and peter quill
does what he always does which is kind
of goof off and joke around that kind of
a thing you know he kind of tells her
like do not come back here like like do
not come here if you do
like you're gonna fall i'm not the kind
of guy who deals with like idol threats
i'm not the kind of guy who's who's
who's you know kind of goes along with
that sort of stuff like i'm a genuine
tough guy right the next scene he goes
flying through a wall he's like my
spleen
and so with that being the case he's
like okay he starts rifling through you
know the various parts of him and he's
like i'm trying to find like i can't
find this thing like like where is this
thing and ultimately he ends up locating
it and so he tells you know this thing
that he's looking for he tells black
swan
like back off like if you don't i will
use this and she's like what is this
some kind of idle threat like a man with
nothing left to lose thinks he can
intimidate me with some false threat and
he's like okay just remember
i told you so and he takes this little
twig and he throws it into the world
tree right he says say hello to my
little friend
and he throws it into the world tree and
in the world tree basically
turns into groot groot grows to this
monumental size and just
explodes out of castle doom and it's
like oh my god right from there you pick
up with susan and valeria who were going
to the location of doctor doom's power
only to meet with like reed richards
from the main marvel universe
and like the maker and reid is just kind
of like hello susan kind of dismissive
to a degree but then you jump from them
and you pick up with thanos right and
this is probably the coolest moment in
the whole story right thanos shows that
like once god king doom arrives on the
scene
thanos shows up and is like enough and
that's when god king doom greets thanos
and he and he asks him he says like
you've brought this you brought down the
wall
you pierced the shield you did all this
so carefully and costly but for what
right for this like to to bring down
battle world is that really what it was
like do you want to be a baron of the
waste to rule the annihilation horde if
that's what you want to do
then do that right i will permit you to
keep the horde you know and and
basically it's an embodiment of my good
will right i'm presenting you with a
gift and thanos is offended he's like
you present me with a gift
like you forget i was a god once right
the infinity gauntlet
gave me that power and when i was a god
i did not use those powers as a mortal
would as you have
saving what you can no i wielded them as
a god should
and judgment of all living things and
that's when he calls doom out he's like
you're a pretender you're a weak
god right this power controls you you do
not control this power
it is you who should bow to me dr doom
is like but do you have an infinity
gauntlet right now and the response of
thanos is no
but i'm still thanos the mad titan the
great tyrant and that then for you
that will be enough doom plunges his
hand into the heart of thanos and just
incinerates him and he's like it looks
like that's not true and so then he in
turn
looks to annihilus and he's like you owe
me for this you and i you allied
yourself with thanos with the intention
of coming here and bringing down my
empire
i am owed penance for this and so there
are heretics attacking my castle you
will destroy them like your annihilation
horde will travel to this location and
it will destroy them now with the with
the incredible hulks with the world
breakers just kind of
lambasting everything groot making his
way towards galactus and all this
pandemonium happening
suddenly the siege courageous opens and
this is kind of like okay like
something's coming through and then
that's when all these zombies start
pouring out and doom's like crap like
it's what he didn't account for right
like these zombies come pouring through
and there's so many of them and they are
for the most part technically immortal
there's no real way to kill them
they take over these incredible hulks
like that right like i mean literally
they all start falling before the hulks
doom's doing what he can blasting them
with his power and trying to destroy as
many of them as he can
and then suddenly you have black panther
who shows up comes through the siege
courageous with the infinity gauntlet
and says doom
your reign is over and it ends with us
black panther with the infinity gauntlet
versus god king doom with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you